I think the average student loan payment
is about 480 and people have gotten I
mean it's been three years people have
gotten so used to three years three
years that's unbelievable
that's crazy and people have I mean it's
this is your lifestyle now people bought
houses
based off of that they don't have their
student loan payments yes and they
bought cars Dave based on
they don't answer the loan payments they
bought look they traded in that 480
student loan payment for Cardinal for
480 so I won waste a crisis I just
wondered Dave when when those payments
hit August 31st is supposed to be that
that magic date and I just wonder how
this is going to affect people's
Financial world